جميع الاطفال كبروا الا واحدا بقي صغيرا
هذه الجمله في قصه بيتركان خياليه التي
تصدر عنها مسرحيات وافلام وغيرها موجود
بالفعل في حياتنا شخصيه طفل صغير اصبح
شابا ورجلا لكنه يرفض ان يكبر مع اصدقائه
ويتحمل المسؤوليه هذه الشخصيه تنتشر بين
الرجال اكثر من النساء يعتمدون على
الاخرين وغالبا ما يفشلون في حياتهم اصبح
في ترفان متلازمه وتعتبر مصطلحا شائعا في
علم النفس يتناوله الاطباء ويضعون له خطه
علاجيه وهو امر لا يمكن ان يتغافل عنه
المحيطون بالشخص الذي يواجه اعراض هذه
المتلازمه
المزيد مع علاء
متلازمه بيتر بان في الحياه او شخصيه
الشاب او الرجل الذي يرفض ان يكبر تظهر
وتعرف من سلوكياتها فهم اتكاليون يحتاج
الاشخاص المصابون بهذه المتلازمه الى وجود
شخص يمسك ايديهم بانجاز اي شيء كذلك غير
مسؤولين ولا يمكن الاعتماد عليهم اذا طلبت
من هذا الشخص ان يفعل شيئا للمساعده
سيتجنب ذلك وسيتصرف وكانه لم يسمعك او سوف
ينسى بالصدفه وهو يتجنب الصراعه باي ثمن
بل يريد ان يفترض ان العالم من حوله مثالي
كما انه لا يريد الخوض في اي حديث سلبي
ايضا لا يشعر بالخطا ابدا بل سيلقي اللوم
على الاخرين فهو دائما ضحيه في تارتان لا
يرى اي حاجه للتغيير ويشعر ان العالم من
حوله على ما يرام ولا يرى اي حاجه لاجراء
اي تعديل لارضائك او لارضاء اي شخص من
حوله
ومن صفاته ايضا ان لديه شخصيه النرجسيه
والانانيه الى جانب انه يرغب في لفت
انتباه الناس من حولك فهو يفكر فقط في
نفسه ويركز على مشاكله متجاهلا مشاكل
الاخرين تماما
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للمتلازمه بيتربين اللي حضرتك
بتقول عليها دي انا ما سمعتش قبل كده عنها
غير من حضرتك دلوقتي فانا ما اعرفهاش قبل
كده يعني هنا الشخص او الراجل بشكل مخصص
يعني بيبقى عايز يحتفظ بطفولته ما يبقاش
يتحمل مسؤوليه يفضل محتفظ بالمتعه بدون
مسؤوليات فكره ان هو يفضل لسه صغير ما
يتنقلش المرحله الاداء والواجبات وهكذا لا
والله انا اول مره اسمع عن حاجه اسمها
متلازمه البيتر بان مش كرتون تقريبا مش
عارف ايه الصراحه هي يعني تقريبا ان
الواحد يبقى الطفل طول عمره حتى بعد ما
يكبر اعتقد ان هو مرض
تقريبا اللي تصايب الرجال اللي هو الناس
الكبيره مثلا مش عاوزه تعيش سنها من
المقصود بها ايه انا ما اعرفش حقيقه ما
قراتش عنها ما اعرفش ايه الموضوع بتاعها
يعني
[موسيقى]
على كل ان ينضم لنا في الاستوديو دكتور
محمد الفريجي اختصاصي العلاج النفسي دكتور
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في صباحنا
العربيه كما شاهدنا هناك بعض الرجال
يفضلون تمسك بمرحله الطفوله والصغار
المتحدث اكثر عن هذه المتلازمه وما هي
اعراضها طيب متلازمه يعني انه في شي شائع
بين الناس بس مش مشخص علميا يعني هي ليست
من ضمن التصنيفات اللي موجوده في
التشخيصات عنا في العلاج النفسي بس صار في
اعراض متشابهه فبداوا يتكلموا عنها
ودانكيل يتكلم 83 انه والله ممكن نسميها
فهو سماها هو اول من اطلق عليها هذا اللقب
واضح انه الناس فاهمين انه شخصيه الطفل
اللي في نيفرلاند وبده يكبر ويضلوا معتمد
على الجنيات اللي ربوه الاخرين وبالتالي
هو بحب يشتغل قرارات بعيش يوم بيوم بيحب
يشعر دائما بانه سعيد مرتاح مش محتاج يعمل
اشي اكثر من هيك
في يعني شيء من الطفوله واضح جدا يقال انه
كل واحد فينا في جزء منه طفل وهذا الجزء
مهم يضل موجود بس المهم انه كمان ما
يتعارض مع مسؤولياتنا طب دكتور محمد هل من
يعانون من متلازمه بيتربان سعداء طالما
انهم يعيشون في حاله انكار للواقع
يعني سؤال مهم هذا لانه خلينا نفكر قديه
هم لو كان عندهم فلوس وكان عندهم امكانيات
انهم ما يشتغلوا وكان عندهم القدره انهم
ما يتحملوا مسؤوليه طب هل فعليا هو عنده
مشكله هو فعليا الاخرين اللي عندهم مشكله
اللي حواليه
ففعليا اللي حواليهم اللي بيكون عندهم
مشكله وهذا بخليني يعني هون اعمل لينك مع
اضطرابات الشخصيه لانه لما نتكلم عن هذا
النوع من الشخصيات في عنا مصطلح اضطراب
الشخصيه الاعتماديه اللي هو بس بطريقه
اخرى
اعتماديه هل يمكن اعتبار ان التربيه
والنشاه الاسريه هي المسؤوله عن نشاه
اجيال غير مسؤوله واعتماديه
الشخص اللي ما تعلم انه يروح يجيب خبز وهو
صغير يروح ايش يجيب ادفع الفواتير ما تعلم
يروح يجيب الخضره ما تعلم يعمل اشياء في
البيت سواء ولد او بنت وكان في دائما
تدليل ووصلوا له الاكل لعنده بيوصلوا كاسه
المي وفي ناس تخدموا حواليه عنا مشكله
طبعا راح يكون في عنده مشكله سواء كانت
اعتماديه سواء كانت تكبر سواء كانت عدم
تخطيط للمستقبل عدم ادراك بعدين شو لازم
اعمل بحياتي طب دكتور محمد يعني ليش ما
منشوف ليش دائما كانه بتصيب الرجال بنشوف
فيه ترفان ما بنشوف مثلا وانت المؤمن يعني
في حدا قال انه يعني هذا تبرير شوي بعتبره
للذكور قال لانه مطلوب من الرجل دائما ان
يكون مسؤول ومطلوب منه هو ان يكون رب
العائله فلما هو يتخلى عن مسؤوليات وببين
انه عنده مشكله يعني هو تبرير يمكن ينفهم
في بعض الثقافات يعني كونه انه البنت مش
مطلوبه بس يعني انا اظن انه لا في شيء
اعمق من هيك له علاقه في اضطرابات الشخصيه
هلا اضطرابات الشخصيه بشكل عام في التصنيف
النفسي بتصيب الرجال اكثر من النساء طب هل
من خطه علاجيه دكتور ام انه الامر صعب
لما يخضع لما يقتنع اصلا انه في مشكله
يعني
نهدت لانه اضطرابات الشخصيه كلهم اه صعب
اه عاده لانه حتى يقتنع يعني لما يكون
مثلا هذا زوجوه اهله
وامنوا له اشياء كتير مثلا وهو شايف انه
الحيوان ما في شيء وشريكه حياته بدات
تعاني بدها تروح تجيب وتودي وتودي الاولاد
على المدرسه
طول اليوم انه بده يشتري العاب بلاي ستيشن
او بده يلعب في البيت يعني طيب هذا كيف
بده يكون التعامل معه اذا ما اقتنع انه في
مشكله اول شيء بده يقتنع انه في مشكله دور
شريك الحياه او الناس اللي حواليه يتعلموا
كيف يتعاملوا معاه بدون ما يصير في عداء
وغضب ومشاكل والعلاج النفسي قطعا الارشاد
النفسي بده يكون مفيد له حتى يعرف كيف
يتصرف يتحمل مسؤوليات
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور محمد الفريج
اختصاصي العلاج النفسي شكرا